if there's money in the bank account but
there's not Health in my body and I'm
still chasing money I got my priorities
wrong if there's money in the bank
account but there's not Health in my
marriage I got my priorities wrong some
people criticize chasing money to their
detriment and it's really an act of
foolishness because money is a tool you
got to support your family you got to
build your business and you got to have
an emergency fund you know we're on a
mission to help 1 million Purpose Driven
people create a full-time living doing
what they love will make it a difference
with YouTube and to experience that
success without losing their soul we
sometimes don't say that last line but
it's very much a part of our company
ethos